optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking when I also personal
question now it is soon I'm a cybernetic
organism living tissue over metal
endoskeleton this episode is brought to
you by wealthfront and this is a very
unique sponsor wealthfront is a
massively disruptive in a good way set
it and forget it investing service led
by technologists from places like Apple
and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in wealth
front so the question is why why is it
so popular why is it unique because you
can get services previously reserved for
the ultra wealthy but only pay pennies
on the dollar for them and this is
because they use smarter software
instead of retail locations bloated
sales teams etc and I'll come back to
that in a second I suggest you check out
wealthfront calm forward slash Tim take
the risk assessment quiz which only
takes two to five minutes and they'll
show you for free exactly the portfolio
they put you in and if you just want to
take their advice run with it do it
yourself you can do that or as I would
you can set it and forget it and here's
why the value of wealth front is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint and
little things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than ten asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealthfront as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
oh point two five percent per year on
assets above the first fifteen thousand
which is managed for free if you use my
link wealthfront calm forward slash Tim
that is less than five dollars a month
to invest a thirty thousand dollar
account for instance
now normally when I have a sponsor on
the show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get $15,000 managed for
free if you decide to open an account
but just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront calm forward slash Tim it's
fast it's free there's no downside that
I can think of just take a look see what
portfolio they would create for you and
you can use that information however you
want wealthfront calm forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs 99designs is a great partner
for creating and growing your business
it's a one-stop shop for all of your
graphic design needs whether that's a
logo website business card or anything
else i use 99designs to get book cover
prototypes for the 4-hour body which
went on to become a number one New York
Times bestseller I also use them for
banner ads illustrations and other
things with 99 designs designers around
the world to compete to create the best
design for you you give feedback and
then pick your favorite you end up happy
or you get your money back it's very
simple you can check out a few of my own
designs and those of yours meaning Tim
Ferriss show listeners at 99 designs.com
/em and right now my listeners you guys
will get a free 99 dollar upgrade on
your first design that's 99 designs.com
a forward slash Tim check it out
hello ladies and germs this is tim
ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the tim ferriss show this is a
special edition where i'm going to share
an excerpt from my favorite book of all
time and in fact it is a collection of
letters roughly 2,000 years old that i
reread at least once a quarter from
seneca the younger these are the moral
letters to Luke ilyas that I've compiled
into the Tao of Seneca and this
particular example is a letter 17 on
philosophy and riches and Seneca takes a
little while with his preamble to get
warmed up but my favorite portion begins
with I might close my letter at this
point so you can use that as a bookmark
I might close my letter at this point
and I was talking to a friend of mine
about Seneca he's a huge fan also and he
said what I agree with and that is I
went back to my notes to start to
compile a list of the ideas I had the
biggest impact on me letter by letter
but going through I realized that what
makes Seneca so unique is the common
threads that flow through different
letters so it's very hard to just take
one letter although they are valuable so
I encourage you to check out all of
these letters and you can find them at
audible.com forward slash Tim's books
it's a three-volume set of all of these
letters because I wanted to listen to
them and audio and could not find it
that's how it got created so please
enjoy on philosophy and riches by seneca
and i hope you find it as valuable as I
have
letter 17 on philosophy and riches cast
away everything of that sort if you are
wise nay rather that you may be wise
strive toward a sound mind at top speed
and with your whole strength if any bond
holds you back untie it or sever it but
you say my estate delays me I wish to
make such disposition of it that it may
suffice for me when I have nothing to do
lest either poverty be a burden to me or
I myself a burden to others you do not
seem when you say this to know the
strength and power of that good which
you are considering you do indeed grasp
the all important thing the great
benefit which philosophy confers but you
do not yet discern accurately its
various functions nor do you yet know
how great is to help we receive from
philosophy and everything everywhere how
to use Cicero's language it not only
suckers us in the greatest matters but
also descends to the smallest take my
advice call wisdom into consultation she
will advise you not to sit forever at
your ledger doubtless your object what
you wish to attain by such postponement
of your studies is that poverty may not
have to be feared by you but what if it
is something to be desired riches have
shut off many a man from the attainment
of wisdom poverty is unburdened and free
from care when the trumpet sounds the
poor man knows that he is not being
attacked when there is a cry of fire he
only seeks a way of escape and does not
ask what he can save if the poor man
must go to see the harbor does not
resigned nor do the wharves bustle with
the retinue of one individual no throng
of slaves surrounds the poor man slaves
for whose mouths the master must covet
the fertile crops of regions beyond the
sea it is easy to fill a few stomachs
when they are well trained and craved
nothing else but to be filled
hunger costs but little squeamishness
costs much poverty is contented with
fulfilling pressing needs why then
should you reject philosophy as a
comrade even the rich man copies her
ways when he is in his senses if you
wish to have leisure for your mind
either be a poor man or resemble a poor
man study cannot be helpful unless you
take pains to live simply and living
simply is voluntary poverty away then
with all excuses like I have not yet
enough when I have gained the desired
amount then I shall devote myself wholly
to philosophy and yet this ideal which
you are putting off and placing second
to other interests should be secured
first of all you should begin with it
you retort I wish to acquire something
to live on yes but learn while you are
acquiring it for if anything forbids you
to live nobly nothing forbids you to die
nobly there is no reason why poverty
should call us away from philosophy
known or even actual want for when
hastening after wisdom we must endure
even hunger men have endured hunger when
their towns were besieged and what other
reward for their endurance did they
obtain than that that they did not fall
under the conquerors power how much
greater is the promise of the prize of
everlasting liberty and the assurance
that we need fear neither God nor man
even though we starve we must reach that
goal armies have endured all manner of
want have lived on roots and have
resisted hunger by means of food too
revolting to mention all this they have
suffered to gain a kingdom and what is
more marvelous to gain a kingdom that
will be another's will any man hesitate
to endure poverty in order that he may
free his mind from madness therefore one
should not seek to lay up riches first
one may attain to philosophy however
even without money for the journey it is
indeed so
after you have come to possess all other
things should you then wish to possess
wisdom also is philosophy to be the last
requisite in life a sort of supplement
nay your plan should be this be a
philosopher now whether you have
anything or not for if you have anything
how do you know that you have not too
much already but if you have nothing
seek understanding first before anything
else but you say I shall lack the
necessities of life in the first place
you cannot lack them because nature
demands but little and the wise man
suits his needs to nature but if the
utmost pinch of need arrives he will
quickly take leave of life and cease
being a trouble to himself if however
his means of existence our meager and
scanty he will make the best of them
without being anxious or worried about
anything more than the bare necessities
he will do justice to his belly and his
shoulders with free and happy spirit he
will laugh at the bustling of rich men
and the flurried ways of those who are
hastening after wealth and say why of
your own accord postpone your real life
to the distant future shall you wait for
some interest to fall due or for some
income on your merchandise or for a
place in the will of some wealthy old
man when you can be rich here and now
wisdom offers wealth and ready money and
pays it over to those in whose I she has
made wealth superfluous these remarks
refer to other men you are nearer the
rich class change the age in which you
live and you have too much but in every
age what is enough remains the same I
might close my letter at this point if I
had not got you into bad habits one
cannot greet parthian royalty without
bringing a gift and in your case I
cannot say farewell without paying a
price but what of it I shall borrow from
Epicurus the acquisition of riches has
been for many men not an end
but a change of troubles I do not wonder
for the fault is not in the wealth but
in the mind itself that which had made
poverty a burden to us has made riches
also a burden just as it matters little
whether you lay a sick man on a wooden
or on a golden bed for whithersoever he
be moved he will carry his malady with
him so one need not care whether the
diseased mind is bestowed upon riches or
upon poverty his malady goes with the
man Sarah well hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email for me every Friday then
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do it
could include favorite articles that i
have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four hour work
week dot com that's four hour work week
com all spelled out and just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up I hope you
enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
99designs 99designs is a great partner
for creating and growing your business
it's a one-stop shop for all of your
graphic design needs whether that's a
logo website business card or anything
else i use 99designs to get book cover
prototypes for the 4-hour body which
went on to become a number one New York
Times bestseller I also use them for
banner ads illustrations and other
things with 99 designs designers around
the world to compete to create the best
design for you you give feedback and
then pick your favorite you end up happy
or you get your money back it's very
simple you can check out a few of my own
designs and those of yours meaning Tim
Ferriss show listeners at 99 designs.com
forward slash Tim and right now my
listeners you guys will get a free 99
dollar upgrade on your first design
that's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim
check it out
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront is a massively
disruptive in a good way set it and
forget it investing service led by
technologists from places like Apple and
world-famous investors it has exploded
in popularity in the last two years and
they now have more than two and a half
billion dollars under management in fact
some of my very good friends investors
in Silicon Valley have millions of their
own money in wealth front so the
question is why why is it so popular why
is it unique because you can get
services previously reserved for the
ultra wealthy but only pay pennies on
the dollar for them and this is because
they use smarter software instead of
retail locations bloated sales teams etc
and I'll come back to that in a second I
suggest you check out wealthfront calm
forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz which only takes two to
five minutes and they'll show you for
free exactly the portfolio they put you
in and if you just want to take their
advice run with it do it yourself you
can do that or as I would you can set it
and forget it and here's why the value
of wealth front is in the automation of
habits and strategies that investors
should be using on a regular basis but
normally aren't great investing is a
marathon not a sprint and little things
that you may or may not be familiar with
like automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront as I mentioned since
it's using software instead of retail
locations etc can offer all of this at
low costs that were previously
completely impossible right off the bat
you never pay commissions or counties
for everything they charge oh point two
five percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront com4 / tim that is less than
five dollars a month to invest eight
thirty thousand dollar account for
instance now normally when I have a
spots around the show is because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed
to here's the deal they wanted to
sponsor this podcast but because of SEC
regulations companies that invest your
money are not allowed to use client
testimonials so I couldn't be a user and
have
on the podcast but I've been so
impressed by wealthfront that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss show listener you'll get $15,000
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront calm
forward slash Tim it's fast it's free
there's no downside that I can think of
just take a look see what portfolio they
would create for you and you can use
that information however you want
wealthfront calm forward slash tim and
until next time thank you for listening